C'est le 27 octobre 1946, lorsque la constitution de la IVème république fut publiée au journal officiel
que figurait en son préambule les mots suivants "la loi garantit à la femme, dans tous les domaines, des droits
égaux à ce de l'homme". C'est l'article 3.
Nous avons donc choisi, en France, d'inscrire dans la constitution que la femme serait l'égale de l'homme.
J'imagine donc que depuis 70 ans on a quand même eu le temps de tout mettre en place pour que nous puissions parvenir à cette égalité.
Quoi ? La situation est encore merdique et inégaliaire ? Après 70 ans ? Cyrusly ?!
Alors attention, j'exagère un poil. Sur le dernier siècle, d'immenses progrès ont heureusement été réalisés en France
et l'histoire politique et sociale de cette période reflète un mouvement d'émancipation progressif des femmes.
Lutte après lutte, les femmes ont gagné des droits et c'était pas couru d'avance.
Parce que, comme dit Corneille, "on vient de loin". Alors on vit chaque jour comme le dernier.
Et c'est toujours intéressant de se rappeler qu'en moins de 100 ans, un gros travail a été fait sur l'égalité homme-femme d'un point de vue législatif.
Dans les grandes lignes, depuis 1944, elles ont pu récupérer le contrôle de leur parole citoyenne avec le droit de vote.
Depuis 1965, le contrôle de leur vie professionnelle. Puisqu'une loi les autorise alors à excercer une profession sans l'autorisation de leur mari.
Et depuis 1975, le contrôle de leur corps avec la loi Veil autorisant l'interruption volontaire de la grossesse, IVG.
Alors là bien sûr vous vous dites que c'est évident. Mais le truc c'est qu'aujourd'hui, puisqu'on est né avec ces acquis,
on réalise pas forcément qu'il y a 75 ans (ce qui est peut être l'âge de votre grand-mère), qu'une femme n'avait pas le droit de voter.
Et le combat n'est pas près de s'arrêter.
Car il y a toujours un écart entre le moment où une décision est prise d'un point de vue législatif et le moment où elle finit par être parfaitement appliquée.
Aujourd'hui, le gros point noir de la France en matière d'égalité homme-femme dans les classements internationaux concerne le milieu professionnel.
Alors, cela passe entre autre par un problème de parité homme-femme concernant les postes à responsabilité :
je vous invite à aller regarder le visage des patrons du CAC40, ou même celui de leur conseil d'administration.
De nombreuses lois ont donc été votées à l'Assemblée Nationale pour garantir cette parité et certaines concernent tout particulièrement la parité
homme-femme en politique. François Hollande lui même s'était engagé dans ses promesses de campagne à montrer l'exemple
et à deux ou trois remaniements près, le dernier en date est représentatif d'une parité parfaite. Bravo François !
Mais quand on sort du premier cercle ministres et secrétaires d'état pour redescendre sur mes chouchous que sont les députés, là ça pue !
L'alarme a été tirée par le haut conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes lors de la publication de son guide 2016 de la parité
qui a relevé qu'en juin 2016, seul 26,2% des élus de l'Assemblée Nationale sont des femmes.
Pour donner une meilleure idée, sur un classement de 191 pays, la France se place à la 60ème place, au niveau de l'Irak.
Alors perso, autant je me réjouirais d'être au même niveau de l'Irak dans un classement sur la qualité du sable ou sur le niveau d'ensoleillement annuel,
autant dans un classement international sur la parité... ça craint.
Et ce qui est vraiment chaud, c'est qu'il y a 4 ans, on était 36ème. Alors si ça peut vous rassurer : on a pas fait marche arrière, on avance juste moins vite que les autres.
Ce qui maintenant que j'y pense, en soi, n'est pas hyper rassurant non plus.
Et ce n'est pas faute de légiférer, puisqu'une loi de 2014 prévoit le doublement des sanctions financières imposées aux partis politiques qui ne présentent pas
un nombre égal de femmes et d'hommes candidats. Alors pas de chance pour cette année, puisqu'elle ne rentrera en vigueur qu'à partir des législatives de 2017.
Comme d'habitude en fait, on légifère mais on tarde à appliquer.
Mais le problème, c'est que ce n'est pas le cas qu'en politique. J'en ai juste parlé en premier puisqu'ils sont supposés montrer l'exemple
car ils sont à l'initiative des lois visant à corriger les problèmes d'égalité.
Non, le problème de parité touche énormément de secteurs.
Encore une fois, selon le haut conseil à l'égalité, pour la partie média, les femmes représentent 49,6% de l'auditoire mais seulement 8% des présentateurs.
Pour le sport, elles sont 30,4% des licenciés pour 10,5% des présidents de fédérations.
Et pour la partie éducation, elles représentent 55,2% des étudiants pour 15,6% des présidents d'universités.
En revanche, elles surpondèrent certains secteurs et elles occupent 80% des emplois précaires.
On aurait pu continuer comme ça pendant un moment, Natoo a d'ailleurs fait une excellente vidéo sur le sujet du YouTube Game :
par exemple, les femmes surreprésentent la catégorie Beauté, mais sont quasi absentes de la catégorie Humour.
[Natoo] "Il y a très peu de filles dans le classement des 100 premiers Youtubers français. Sur 100, il y en a seulement une dizaine.
[Natoo] Et dans cette poignée de femmes, 2 font de l'humour !
[Natoo] Toujours dans ce classement des 100 premiers Youtubers, sur la dizaine de filles présentes, 80% font de la beauté."
L'autre grosse partie dans l'égalité professionnelle concerne l'égalité des salaires à poste équivalent.
Et là, on est vraiment pas bon. Selon le rapport annuel du forum économique mondial concernant les inégalités femme-homme,
la France se retrouve à la 132ème place sur 145 pays en matière d'égalité salariale.
Je ne vous refait pas la blague sur notre position dans la liste. Mais savoir que l'on se situe, sur le plan des inégalités salariales, derrière l'Azerbaïdjan,
le Tadjikistan, le Zimbabwe ou la Russie fera peut-être évoluer les idées reçues que l'on a sur la place de la femme dans ces pays...
ou bien dans le nôtre, c'est selon !
Ce qui devient vraiment problématique, c'est que forcément, quand l'accès au sommet de la pyramide de l'emploi ou à un salaire correct est inégal,
la retraite le devient aussi. Si on se fie à l'étude de la DREES (Direction de la Recherche, des Etudes, de l'Evaluation et des Statistiques) publiée en 2015
les femmes perçoivent une pension de retraite moyenne de 967 euros brut par mois, contre 1610 euros pour les hommes, soit un écart de 40%.
Ce dernier tend à diminuer lorsque l'on tient compte des pensions de réversion ou du minimum vieillesse mais il atteint tout de même 26%.
A la lumière de tous ces chiffres, j'espère que vous comprenez mieux l'initiative d'origine islandaise qui avait rayonné jusqu'en France et fait grand bruit dans les
médias, en invitant les femmes à arrêter de travailler le 7 novembre 2016 à 16h34. Pourquoi cette date ?
Parce qu'au vu de l'écart de salaire femme-homme, il s'agit de la date symbolique à partir de laquelle les hommes auront gagné ce que gagnent les femmes en une année.
L'idée, c'était alors de mobiliser un maximum de monde pour attirer l'attention, entre autre, des futurs candidats à la présidentielle.
On est donc l'un des pays d'Europe qui rame le plus sur la partie égalité économique. Alors heureusement, notre classement global et notre honneur reste sauf
grâce à de bonnes performances dans d'autres domaines comme par exemple l'égalité d'accès à la santé ou à l'éducation.
Mais enfin ça c'est pour le moment. Parce que manque de bol, une minorité de plus en plus bruyante
semble motivée à revenir sur certains droits fondamentaux des femmes (par contre coucher avec son cousin c'est toujours bon).
Et trop souvent, des hommes politiques, puisqu'on a vu la répartition femme-homme à l'assemblé nationale,
semblent prêts à prendre des décisions et voter des lois qui concerneront les femmes. Notamment sur la loi Veil.
Et je comprends que ça puisse rendre dingue. Muriel Robin a d'ailleurs très bien résumé son point de vue lors d'un coup de gueule dans l'émission 'Salut les terriens!' de Thierry Ardison.
[Muriel Robin] "Non mais ça me fatigue, ces hommes qui décident pour des femmes. [...] Ca va, ça se passe bien entre vous les mecs ?
[Muriel Robin] Tout va bien ? Dites-nous, hein ! On couche, on pond... ce qui vous arrange ! Devant, derrière, la bouche, dites-nous !
[Muriel Robin] Trois enfants ? deux ? On les garde ? on prend ceux des autres ? Dites-nous, hein ! dites-nous. Dites-nous comment il faut faire !"
Sachant que plutôt que de s'occuper de réactualiser le débat sur l'avortement (en fronçant les sourcils),
faire la chasse au burkini (coucou Manuel Valls !) ou contre le planning familial (coucou Marion Maréchal Le Pen !),
les politiques pourraient s'occuper d'autres problématiques qui touchent les femmes et entraînent malheureusement parfois la nécessité d'avorter.
Plutôt que de s'intéresser en fait à ce que les femmes devraient faire ou ne pas faire, l'Etat devrait s'intéresser
à ce qu'il pourrait faire pour elles. Comme par exemple, endiguer l'explosion du nombre de viol ces dernières années,
avec un nombre d'agressions qui a augmenté de 18% entre 2010 et 2014.
Juste pour que vous preniez bien conscience des chiffres : on parle de 12 768 viols dénoncés à la police en 2014 soit un viol déclaré toutes les 40 minutes.
Et je ne parle que des viols déclarés, pas de toutes les victimes qui n'osent pas porter plainte. Parce que sinon, on monte à un viol toutes les 9 minutes. C'est énorme...
Même si on peut toujours aller plus loin sur un plan législatif et serrer la vis, ce sont plutôt certaines mentalités,
certains comportements, voire visions parfois archaïques de la société qu'il convient de faire évoluer
si on veut espérer avancer vers une meilleure égalité entre femmes et hommes en France.
Et ça commence par des choses aussi basiques qu'améliorer la répartition des tâches ménagères dans le couple
ou bien que de ne pas associer le ministère des droits des femmes à celui de la famille et de l'enfance lors du premier remaniement venu
parce qu'il ne manque plus que le ministère de la cuisine pour que le combo soit parfait.
Plutôt que d'être en retard, soyons de nouveau en avance. Parce que pour montrer l'exemple et faire la leçon au reste du monde, il faudrait déjà que nous soyions exemplaires.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à le faire tourner si c'est le cas
et à lâcher un commentaire ou un 'poce bleu', pour aider au référencement.
Si le concept d'égalité homme-femme ne te semble pas logique, je t'invite à regarde ce 'Coup de Phil'
sur le féminisme de Simone de Beauvoir (c'est un de mes préférés), je te le mets en description.
Un grand merci aux Tipeers qui soutiennent le projet et big-up à toutes les personnes qui soutiennent la chaîne en partageant son contenu.
Vous pouvez me suivre sur Facebook, Twitter, Snapchat.
Love, Peace, Tchao !